the rockies have acquired michael
gibbons the right-handed reliever from
the baltimore orioles the san diego
padres once again making some moves they
acquired mitch moreland from the boston
red sox in exchange for a couple of
prospects there's trent grisham about to
lead it off here for the padres 2-2
pitch
and this one is lying to center field a
base hit for trent grisham good way to
start the day for the padres
single gets it started for grisham so
lead runner on and brings up fernando
tatis junior
when he gets hit in the backside
a 1-1 pitch coming up and in and it hits
him the four seamer right in the left
hip
it's going to hurt for a while but
hopefully it hurts more for castellani
one out and two on and eric hosmer
284 six homers 22 runs batted in
osmer drives this to deep right field
back goes blackman at the wall it is
gone
a three-run home run for eric hosmer his
seventh of the year and the padres jump
out to a three-nothing lead in denver
today
rush to deep right center field ball
going ball long gone for eric hosmer
three-run shot that's more like my san
diego padres they have a three-nothing
lead boy a kick in the gut for the
rockies gotta love the three-run shot in
the first frame for the friars haddock's
got a three-nothing lead even before he
threw a pitch today three eleven nine
homers and 19 runs batted in for story
so get a foul tip and he strikes him out
needed that had a good story for the
first down here in the first inning two
away for charlotte blackman
at 362 with four homers and 28 runs
batted in
swinging a miss and he strikes out
blackman so nicely done works his way
around a lead-off walk three-nothing
padre
here's grisham he's saturday with a
single scored ahead on the home run by
hajj
threw it gross about it for the second
time and he lines this one to right
field that's going to get in and by
blackburn is heading for third bases
hedges he'll be waved around padre is
going to try to get him in here comes
the throw they'll be none hedges is in
and standing at third base is trent
grisham and the padres take a four
nothing lead
second hit of the day for trent grisham
now tatis rips this into left field and
scoring from third will be gresham tatis
is gonna throw the brakes on around
first base and the padres take a
five-nothing lead five to nothing padres
have the lead chris paddock back on the
hill inning number two the left hand
hitting second baseman that's ryan
mcmahon
swinging them in saying it's the
fastball that he gets by him third
strikeout for paddock on the day
two pitch in the dirt swung on and
missed and throw him out and they do
that is three straight strikeouts for
panic most home runs by shortstop since
2016 trevor story on top of that list
story struck out in the first inning
and a foul tip into the catcher's mitt
for strike three strikes out in the
fourth inning at six strikeouts for
paddock one out man aboard for the
padres jake cronin worth
and a line shot throw to first out of
first what a dart from nolan
not like hosner got far off but they
double them up
it is first and third with one out what
two pits
in the air to right field has blackman
going back onto the turn of the track to
make the catch tagging at third and
scoring his time france going to second
base head first he is pro far it's a sac
fly for hedges and the padres add on and
take a six nothing lead blackman in the
box charlie is struck out in flight out
just the third opportunity on the day
for the rockies with a man in scoring
position
this ball is to hosmer and
that is not handled by tatis here comes
tapia home nolan to third i think osmond
got a little casual with that
that ball's hit he's not really running
towards the back
and so by the time he realized hey i've
got to get there
he's trying to find the bag
as he catches it and steps on and goes
off his glove three and two on mcmahon
charlie off and this is line to left
center field no little score charlie is
going to stop going after he went
halfway around the bag at second
and ryan mcmahon coming through his 18th
ribby six to two
hosmer three-run home run in the first
and a single in the fifth he's two for
three
up the middle nice stop hampson good
play on the fox double play how special
was that on both ends of the middle
first hamson and then how about the uh
the pivot throw by mcmahon good thing
he's got a strong arm because he needed
every bit of that jay cronenworth single
back in the first inning a one for three
day for the padres second baseman
this is driven to deep right center
field back goes blackman looking up and
it is gone
jake croninworth with his fourth home
run of the year a two run shot and the
padres take an 8-2 lead in denver
jake cronenworth connects on this one
second home run of the day and the
padres enjoy a six-run lead well this
kid is something else corona brings home
tatis and the padres back in front by
six and out here in the eighth and jerks
and pro farms at a one for three days
single
in the sixth inning his last time up
they off pitch
and this one is driven out to deep left
field back goes tapia at the wall that
ball is gone a home run
jerks and profar adds to the padres
total today that's home run number three
for san diego and number three on the
year for profar
padres up there leading nine to two in
denver today
that bat that was nine pitch at bat he
cranks it out of the yard to left two
out to the base is empty for grisham
this one driven out towards deep right
center field back goes blackman looking
up and that ball is gone
home run for trent grisham and the
padres connect on their fourth home run
of the day and now take a 10-2 lead
home run number eight for trent grisham
in a padres uniform
all part of the fun in denver no two
machado grounds it right side into right
field a base hit tatis being waved
around blackman is up and throwing it'll
be cut off and the padres taking a 11-2
lead
runner on here for the padres in the
ninth inning brings up josh naylor
naylor drives this one deep far to right
field it will be gone
only question fair foul it's a two run
shot for naylor five home runs today for
the padres
2 padres
rocking the rocks in denver
we know that josh nader likes to swing
the bat and he likes to swing it hard so
when he makes contact you bet he almost
put it down the the walkway there
rockies get two base runners on with two
outs in the inning and
that'll bring up drew butera
how about a ground ball right side it is
garcia he'll tag the bag at second and
that's the ball game nicely done as the
padres rock the rocks today a 13-2 win
for the padres they've taken two of the
first three games in denver